[Music]
sometimes it's nice to just
kick back and take it slow
really slow
so what if evolution had the same
mindset
and decided to take its time before
getting rid of some
prehistoric creatures what if
the giant sloth was still around
what would it get up to in the 21st
century
could modern day humans even handle
giant sloths
and what does this have to do with my
guacamole
this
is what if and here's what would happen
if
giant sloths didn't go extinct
giant sloths are a lot like their modern
day descendants
they were slow harmless and well
adorable the key difference
was that they were bigger and i mean a
lot bigger
the largest of these tardy titans would
have reached
up to 7 meters tall and weighed in
at over 6 300 kilograms
giant sloths evolved in south america
about 35 million years ago
and thanks to several specimens we've
found in good condition
we have a pretty good idea of how they
lived their lives that is until
11 000 years ago when they went extinct
during the ice age
but what if that wasn't the story
what if they stuck around well
if they were still alive they would live
in forests or
bushy areas found in north and south
america
these forests would be their vegan
buffet
giant sloths were herbivores that could
stand up on their hind legs to grasp
tree branches with their thick claws
and snack on leaves some of them even
had
tongues similar to giraffes and could
use them
to reach the extra tasty leaves
delicious
it's a pretty good skill to have because
these gentle giants
would need to eat about 60 000 calories
per day
that's as much as an african elephant's
daily meal plan
so it sounds like even in the 21st
century
giant sloths would have a pretty relaxed
lifestyle
but what would it be like for us
well knowing humans we'd probably give
them a job
and use them for labor the giant sloths
might be used as transportation at least
until we
realized that that idea sucks
hope you're not in a hurry
some giant sloths were the size of an ox
so
they might be able to help us out on
farms by using the old carrot dangling
in front of their face trick we could
have them plowing fields
but is anyone really going to invest in
a work sloth
i mean they're not really known for
their speedy work ethic
there's got to be something else they
could do
well it turns out their biggest
contribution was
avocados yeah avocados
people love avocados but the giant sloth
really loved avocados
they would eat about 200 avocados per
day
it's estimated that if 80 000 giant
sloths roamed the earth
they would eat as many avocados each
year as are consumed in the entire
united states
ah i hear what you're saying how is
eating so many avocados
a contribution well get this
have you ever heard of kopi luwak it's
the most expensive coffee in the world
kopi luak is made when civic cats eat
coffee beans
allowing their internal enzymes to seep
into the beans
creating more amino acids and shortening
the peptides
this changes the flavor of the coffee
and then
you know they poop it out and people buy
it
and they think it's a delicacy
it's a bit nutty
we might be able to do something similar
with the avocado pit
considering the avocado pit is much
larger we could be looking at a good
investment here
could guacamole made from the avocado
seeds
deposited by a giant sloth become a
delicacy
you could start a gourmet avocado farm
with a bunch of sloths
eating and pooping out avocado seeds
it would be a great way to start
production as you wouldn't be lacking
fertilizer
that is one big pilot now while it would
be amazing to have
eco-friendly giants helping us with our
farms
sadly it's only a dream
giant sloths are long gone and unless we
do
some huge genetic experiments
they're gonna stay that way but wait a
minute
that's not a bad idea
what if we invested in the technology to
give these animals
another roll of the dice what if
extinct animals could be brought back to
life
well that's a story for another
what if